let's move on to news headlines speaking
of things that need to be said
number one Tucker Carlson who I think is
one of the most important voices in
America right now had an excellent
monologue last night and his message
needs to be heard loud and clear
particularly by one person who hopefully
was watching he would change the course
of this country's future if the justice
department rounded up the leaders of n
Tifa tomorrow along with every single
person caught on camera torturing a
building destroying a monument defacing
a church and put them all in shackles
and then frog-marched them in front of
cameras like ms-13 and called them what
they actually are domestic terrorists
not protesters not civil rights activist
not seen any contributors but domestic
terrorists that would be their new
government approved title once they're
charged it's official in fact they are
literally as a factual matter accused
terrorists and that would change minds
right away most people don't like
terrorists terrorists will never be
popular even among Democratic voters so
charge them for the crimes they've
committed and call them what they are
right now the opposite is happening the
terrorists are more popular than the
President of the United States and not
just more popular than Donald Trump
personally but more popular than the
system he represents and administers and
it's obvious why our system is weak it
refuses to defend itself
mayor's let new countries sprout in the
middle of their cities our leaders act
like laws are irrelevant everyone
watches this happen it's a potentially
fatal problem weak institutions die
citizens develop contempt for them and
then they get overthrown the same is
true by the way for heads of state when
you refuse to fight for the system you
run you're done spend an hour on Google
and see if you can find a single leader
in the history of the world who stayed
in power after failing to quell a
rebellion you can't by the way that clip
was shared by a media matters person
calling it maybe the most deranged rant
I've heard on Fox News meanwhile he said
that was deranged meanwhile all normal
people think it's one of the say nice
things we've ever heard or at least
recently heard talker is exactly right
and if anyone needs to hear him loud and
clear it's primarily the president now I
know some of you don't like it when I
criticize them I know that that's fine
you don't have to like it but I'm
telling you the fact of the matter
Tucker saying the fact doesn't matter
like it or not Trump is losing right now
I'm not just talking about the polls and
the polls are one indicator but it's not
just about that I don't need I don't
even need to see the polls I don't care
what the polls say Trump is losing right
now make all the lame excuses you want
but if Trump continues tweeting while
America burns he will lose more than
that he will deserve to lose it's better
for his supporters I think to face this
fact now put some pressure on him then
to whisper sweet nothings in his ear
telling him that the law-and-order
tweets are are great and totally
sufficient everyone loves it he's doing
great nothing is wrong they aren't
sufficient everyone doesn't love it and
shouldn't ok the tweeting in general I
think most people and I get it again
your if you're a die-hard you know fan
then then you're always going to love
the tweets but most people are not
diehard fans and never were
Trump won 2016 with 70,000 votes that
gave him the the electoral college
victory while losing the popular vote by
2 million votes this is a he won by a
hair's breadth so I mean the his
supporters have been lying to him he's
been lying to himself since day one
saying that it was some sort of
landslide victory not even close
this needs to be communicated to Trump
in a hurry because right now it's like
the guy isn't even trying he did a town
hall on Fox last night don't know if you
watched this thing and he was asked what
his plan is for a second term now he's
asked by Sean Hannity you couldn't ask
for a friendlier inner of interviewer
and you could ask for an easier question
what's your plan for the second term you
you gotta have an answer to that that's
that's your president you're an
incumbent president running for a second
term somebody asks you what's your plan
for a second term you should be boom
boom boom boom have answers this is what
Trump said let's talk about a second
term
if you here in 131 days from now at some
point in the night or early morning we
can now project Donald J Trump has been
reelected the 45th President of the
United States let's talk had it what's
at stake in this election as you compare
and contrast and what is one of your top
priority items for a second term well
one of the things that will be really
great you know the word experience is
still good I always say talent is more
important that experience I've always
said that but the word experience is a
very important word it's an overt
important meeting I never did this
before I never slept over in Washington
I was in Washington I think 17 times all
of a sudden the president the United
States you know the story of writing
down Pennsylvania Avenue with our first
lady and I say this is great but I
didn't know very many people in
Washington wasn't my thing I was from
Manhattan from New York now I know
everybody and I have great people in the
administration you make some mistakes
like you know an idiot like bolt and all
he want to do is drop bombs on everybody
you don't have to drop bombs on
everybody you have to kill people that's
just nonsense that's that's I don't want
to hear us Trump being Trump I don't
give a damn if it's Trump being Trump
Trump needs to stop being Trump that's
babbling ridiculous nonsense you were
asked a question what's your plan people
actually want to hear it
it's a good question that was not an
answer if the guy can't even tell us
what he wants what he wants to do in a
second term why should anyone vote for
him he literally can't give you a reason
to vote for him other than Joe Biden
blah blah that's not gonna be enough it
was enough against Hillary okay to beat
Hillary all you had to do was say look
at Hillary Hillary Hillary Hillary I
think this time around when you're in
the incumbent and you have a record for
better or worse you need to actually
present a positive reason to vote for
you for you what is good about you
now this excuse that people are
providing for Trump that is that his
supporters are providing Trump is doing
nothing as anarchists destroy the
country the excuse is well we'll let
they let the leftist cities destroy
themselves No
yeah you
that might seem like the sort of tough
approach it's not tough it's weak and
cowardly it's the weakest BS I've ever
heard what you're saying is let's give
the criminals and anarchists everything
they want that'll show them so what
you're doing if you let them destroy
themselves no it's not them destroying
themselves it's allowing criminals and
anarchists to do what they want while
innocent Americans in those cities
suffer Trump is the president of those
people and it's not and you and if
you're next if your next move is to
blame them for living in the city to
begin with that's not gonna be a winning
message wow they deserve it they made a
choice to live in a city because that's
where they found a job hey you might be
able to soothe yourself with that
message that is not a winning message
Trump is the president of those people
he's their president - you're not
punishing the anarchists by letting them
do what they want is it is this what
people do with their kids I guess the
other this explains a lot really it's
not a lot of parents act with their kids
well I'll show them by letting them stay
up all night playing PlayStation they'll
learn their lesson eventually yeah maybe
maybe 30 years from now when they look
back at their wasted childhood that's
when they'll learn their lesson that's
not good enough no they need to learn
their lesson now you're the parent do it
now I certainly hate to compare a
politician to a parent because that's
not the relationship I was supposed to
have with the public but still these
people are acting like children and
worse
that's an insult to children they're
acting like worse than children and they
do need to be punished law and order not
just a tweet
he's floundering it's pathetic he's
gonna lose that's the reality if he
doesn't do something now number two
they're coming for Mount Rushmore now a
report from daily wire says on Thursday
USA Today quoted that a tribal leader of
the Sioux Nation saying that although
Mount Rushmore should not be blown up it
should be removed how do you remove a
mountain I don't know
Oh golly sue president Julian Bear
runner who expresses his disapproval of
President Trump's visit next week to the
Black Hills of South Dakota stated of
Mount Rushmore I don't believe that
should be blown up because it would
cause more damage to the land but he
agrees that it should be removed and
then there's a lot of stuff about how
this is a symbol of Nick Tilson of the
Oglala Lakota tribe said Mont rush Mount
Rushmore is a symbol of white supremacy
of structural racism it's still alive
and well in society today and on and on
and they'll do it they'll do it too
they'll do anything they want okay the
people that are seeking to tear down the
mounting monuments and tear down Western
civilization and all of its icons and
heroes they're just getting whatever
they want and that how that's how we're
again that that's how we're we're
punishing them by just letting them do
it
great strategy wonderful number three
here's something to think about next
time you're at the beach look at this
drone footage of a great white shark
gigantic beast swimming right under
unsuspecting surfers good God Almighty
now you know I like the beach I love the
water but it is kind of a weird thing we
do isn't it I always think if aliens
were to come to this country they would
be they'd be one of the many things
they're very surprised and confused by
they would say why are these humans
gathered around and for no constructive
reason swimming and paddling in this
giant salty deathtrap where man-eating
monsters are lurking in the debts and a
lot of them aren't even doing anything
and if you go to a beach they're just
standing in it letting the the the
ferocious waves pummel them in the face
while they get sand up their shorts and
they do that for an hour and a half and
then they go home what was the point of
this ritual that's what the aliens would
be asking I imagine
of course I'm also assuming that aliens
don't know what an ocean is and if they
didn't have an ocean on their home
planet then there would be no
civilization begin with so you know
there are problems with my hypothetical
but anyway number four
after 30 years the Dixie Chicks are
changing their name they will now be the
chicks not the Dixie Chicks why is the
word Dixie offensive this is this is a
very interesting a lot of ways and it
shows among other things what I'm always
talking about how feminists are
constantly having to take a back seat on
it when I come on a modern Left
feminists are very close to the bottom
of the totem pole there they're almost
at this point they're treated almost
like white men to be a feminist you're
you're you're very you're not that much
you're not that that's that much higher
you know on the hierarchy than white men
are as feminists because all of their
interests are thrown to the side and you
see here so Dixie Chicks changing their
name and they're gonna keep one of the
words they decide to keep chicks which
the feminists have been saying for
decades is offensive and now they're
just the chicks we gotta get rid of
Dixie but not chicks I just think that's
very emblematic of the situation on the
modern left and and of course meanwhile
you've been the Dixie Chicks for 30
years you you're just now deciding that
it's offensive after three decades what
changed your mind what made you realize
that it's offensive well what were you
told in the last year or a few months
really that you didn't know already that
made you decided as offensive now it's
not offensive the word Dixie is not at
all offensive but if you think that it
is what new information were you
provided that brought you to this
conclusion or have you thought that it
was a racist name all along and you did
and so you've just been white
supremacist for thirty years which is it
Dixie Chicks I didn't even know the
Dixie Chicks still it's still still
existent to be honest I had no idea that
they were still out there making music
alright number five a report from Fox
Carolina
very sad disturbing and fury ating story
the forest City Department police
department said a young girl has died
after she was severely injured in a
shooting on Tuesday evening the shooting
and along the intersection of Oak Street
and Harmon Street around 5:00 p.m. the
officers arrived found two individuals
pulling a seven year old girl from a
vehicle and she was suffering a single
gunshot wound to the head
now they arrested Shakeel Marchand
Francis 26 years old charging him with
shooting this girl in the head
they haven't been there's there's no
information about motive or anything not
that motive matters at all with a crime
like this but here's the thing Francis
the monstrous scumbag or alleged monster
scumbag was released from jail just a
few hours before one of the reports I
read said they was released from jail on
different charges other charges I think
it was a assault by pointing a gun at
someone he was one report said three
hours earlier he was released and then
allegedly immediately went and shot a
girl net this goes back to what I've
been the drum I've been banging for
weeks now that if we're going to be
doing reforms reforms that protect black
lives and all lives then rather than
police reform being the first thing we
do we should be looking at reforms that
would prevent murderous sociopaths from
walking the streets because the current
strategy is that criminals dangerous
criminals get out of jail a million
times until they do something so
unbelievably heinous that there's no
choice but to lock them away for and
even then a lot of times it's not
forever it's for no but at least for
many years that's the strategy right now
I mean you had someone who you just you
know if they've committed many crimes
many of them violent and you you just
you know that eventually they're gonna
do something utterly horrible and but
all we do is just wait for them to do
that thing and to that victim even if
it's set a seven-year-old girl
apparently the system is saying well you
know
too bad basically this is what is what
the system is saying to these victims I
I think this should be the reform you
know if you have someone if this is the
crime that he committed assault with a
deadly weapon before what is he doing
back out on the street keep them in jail
this is a dangerous person why are you
letting them out that should be our
reform hey you yeah you
you right you right there hit the
subscribe button right now do it do it
right now I thank you for your
compliance it's somewhat appreciated